he's not going to be president take it
to the bank
so right now mr trump to answer your
call for political honesty i just want
to say
you're not going to be president
what a stupid question that is what a
stupid question
but i watch you a lot you ask a lot of
stupid questions
[Music]
can you can you stay you are fake
[Music]
do i seem rattled
for today
i know how much i hate the slurp but
yeah i actually had to look at you to
make sure that was real
i know so perfect it's almost like i'm
the guy from uh from police academy
yeah yeah maybe not a little bit
so uh that's a horrible opinion
you're a boomer you watch police academy
steve guttenberg just
all of them punches my ticket only the
first seven uh
we have a lot to get to today half asian
lawyer bill richmond is back here in
third chairs
which a lot of people thought he was
dead and people thought you were fired
it's just sometimes
people aren't here for a day you're used
to me being here
always because it's in my contract with
myself
uh quarter black personal contract good
morning audio wave he is
quarter black allegedly and uh morgan
junior cool gerald
a is a father now how's the kid doing
it's kids doing fantastic sleeping shake
weight yet
no no there have been moments of
frustration but not peak
frustration yeah i don't i wouldn't
trust myself with your kid with mine
it'd be fine
with your kid it'd just be a shake so
let's cancel the visitation
[Laughter]
you're no longer the guy you're off the
list uh we're gonna be talking about a
lot
today by the way nick sandman was the
highlight is it sound man or sandman
i mean to the democrats the poor guy who
wrote mr
mr sandman bring me a dream
everyone thinks of mike myers and
someone getting pinned against the wall
with the butcher's knife
no i think of philadelphia where the gay
guys are singing it ruined the song for
me
michael myers michael michael michael
myers was nine halloween
which made me question if anything he
ever did was funny sure do you ever have
something someone does it so bad that it
makes
was this ev was austin powers ever funny
it was
it was retrospective the love guru was
just that bad but that's the problem
with mr uh mr sandman so we'll be
talking about nick sandman we have some
new
info on jacob blake not not flake
uh we'll be talking about what's been
going on in kenosha some people were
shot yesterday
uh i mean listen that's not necessarily
news
uh and we'll be talking about what you
should do and this is my question of the
day because people have been going
around and harassing diners
would be would-be diners in washington
dc right now demanding they put up their
fists and
really assaulting them uh my question to
you out there and i will
do a segment hopefully is helpful some
advice uh you know and i've run it by my
lawyer first my half asian lawyer
i want to know when you think any kind
of force
is appropriate if it's ever appropriate
what do you think someone should do if
someone
costs your wife up against a wall at a
diner demanding through intimidation
that she put up her fist uh we'll also
be responding to you guys in the chat
later on who are mug club members
please subscribe to crowder bits of
course we're available uh on
android on apple podcasts and uh
mug club that's what keeps the show
going do all those things so um
we're gonna be talking about nixon oh
you know what first sorry we always have
sponsors on the show uh we have a new
sponsor this morning i wanna make sure i
have it i don't have my paper but
i believe we've been sponsored by uh uh
yoga with benefits such as increased
flexibility
added muscle tone and improved energy
and vitality
yoga is a great way to start your day
yoga can help you maintain a balanced
metabolism
reduce your weight and attain mystical
union with hanuman the monkey king
tired of worrying about poor heart
health subpar athletic performance
and whether you and hanuman the monkey
king are really you know
okay yoga can help since earning his
path to deification by performing feats
of strength
devotion and courage while helping rama
the avatar of vishnu in countless
exciting incidents
hanuman the monkey king has been quite
the popular fellow
and you and he can attain true oneness
with yoga
yoga stretch your mind
sacrilegious on so many levels it's
interesting right i think people who do
yoga and vishnu will be offended and
then christians get mad because there's
yogurt listen by the way
the christians out there i can praise
jesus and touch my toes
let's yes i don't need to be praying i
can't do the second
so you're saying we should stop courting
lululemon for a sponsorship yeah
yeah i found out that they may be men's
stuff which by the way uh smooth manny
will be on later talking about the cube
according to smooth manny okay the rnc
is going on we have the live stream
tomorrow we love donald trump jr ted
cruz
uh as we do the stream drinking game
patriotic costumes but yesterday was
pretty boring
it was pretty boring there was a couple
of good moments there was a highlight
and that was mr the the 80 million
dollar man
nick sandman let's go to a clip i
believe we must all
embrace our first amendment rights and
not hide in fear of the media
or from the tech companies or from the
outrage mob
either this is worth fighting for
this is worth voting for and this is
what donald
trump stands for thank you all for
listening to me tonight
and one more thing let's make america
great again
by the way can you get the background to
shut up yeah i know that just people
just got scattered
stop the chatter this is a national
television filming
and my favorite part about it was he
called out the media non-stop
and uh let's go right now live to cnn
they have uh
baby bird john kasich speaking um
what are you saying the trump openly
uses political office for re-election
efforts
oh they're so pissed about that
president trump holds office and wants
to be reelected
he looks like the kind of guy who would
send a letter to his congressman before
he was governor and be upset that they
didn't email him back i'm still waiting
on this
zoo to contact your representatives and
i did and he didn't get back to me
that's because
no one gets back to you but i do like
this in the last cnn i had to cover nick
i was watching it on cnn was justice
they didn't comment
at all especially considering that
allegedly from what we don't have the
official numbers
nick sandman got 80 million dollars from
cnn for defamation so they didn't touch
it with a 10-foot pole on air yeah they
just usually they were popping in with
common chapters
like donald trump official investigation
then nick sandman just the whole speech
and then just silence and next speech
i wonder if he negotiated that into the
settlement any time that i speak cnn now
has to cover it
ron edited and i bet you that was a
decision up top like wolf blitzer had no
idea
he was just talking to a speaking spell
that he thought was a camera
like cut the mic like i don't like nick
samuel you're like oh great job wilson
good job okay you're doing it
make sure it's mike's still get you back
in celebrity jeopardy your back's busy
these days but you know i want you back
i got a new low score i think he was
just going to comment i was waiting for
them to just be like
oh lincoln's looking real great
move on really great could you please
remove your shaft from our orifie
mr sandman because it really it still
stings
we're still sore too soon although uh
joe lockhart tweeted uh he's an analyst
so this is as close as he got he said
i'm watching tonight because it's
important
but i don't have to watch this
snot-nosed entitled kid from kentucky
yeah yeah yeah an entitled kid from
kentucky as opposed to those
those contributing black hebrew
israelites and professional protester
nathan phillips who lives off the land
in lois jeans and nike dry fit yeah
exactly who's being picked on here a
giant global network or a kid from yeah
entitled what do you mean he feels like
he's entitled to his reputation
not being slandered labeled a racist
i don't know what i don't know what you
give him you give him an inch
all the legal protections that we are
all entitled to maybe
poor kid wants a life after 17 years old
entitled look that kid was out there
recklessly smiling at people that's true
yeah you know you
violently do that what is this the 1800s
come on wait what was he doing
clearly he was out there schmidt that
was a grin of white supremacists it was
i watched it i heard his speech i
actually thought for the first time you
know what this kid was scared
this you have a bunch of black hebrew
israelites who by the way don't believe
that it's
possible for you to avoid the fiery
depths of hell
if you lack a certain level of melanin
in your skin that's what they believe
their entire belief system is predicated
on the idea that jesus was black
and you are not uh that's probably why
you can't touch your toes
he's not answering he's listening to the
new cardi b mixtape
so block hebrew israelites and then this
guy comes up banging a drum nathan flips
i don't want to rehash it but
it is amazing that cnn or at least
someone at cnn still doubles down i
don't want to listen to this snot-nosed
entitled kid
i don't know okay listen i understand
that he feels entitled uh
to 80 million dollars which jokes on you
but
you guys feel entitled to just why
exactly yeah you know who else feels
the judge feels that he's entitled to
the 80 million dollars because that's
that's kind of a legend
or as brian selter calls it simple go
away money
oh that's all it's nothing more than
nuisance money is what it is
it's what we'll talk about in reliable
sources it's nothing more than news and
it's nothing more it's newsen's money
i love how after that i just imagine
they came to him and they were like
it was 80 million not 80 oh yeah
yeah exactly what yeah but that's what i
get is 80
i feel like the entire rnc last night
all the speeches were designed
to trigger the left i think trump was
like sitting there like okay who could
we get
i'm gonna pardon a black guy which by
the way was brilliant that he pardoned a
black man
he was talking about an fbi agent how
they'd become friends
it's all the elements of a great story
that the left hates
you have a black guy you have an fbi
agent and there's reconciliation
through the lord jesus christ look at
that i show up in my mouth
i can't be i think my reliable sources
can't be holy texts
it's nuisance money
and then you have pompeo obviously from
israel is like okay just piss people off
there because the capitals in israel
oh my god new citizens new citizens
being brought into this country like he
did
everything possible to just piss them
off and he's like let's have
[ __ ]
in the rose garden you have the pirate
you have the lady in the in the hijab
yeah and then it was just like the
birthday
club of diversity i do i do appreciate
that you know there's the maintained
lack of consistency on the democratic
side because they're out there saying
well we need to just
you know let into undocumented
immigrants let them all in
everything's fine no big deal i can't
believe these people are coming in the
united states
and getting admitted yeah legally
legally yeah they're coming in the right
way don't they know we have a doggy door
[Laughter]
in the sonoran desert it's we do know
but it's hard to drive a caravan
through well listen i thought i was
thinking no it's a dodge caravan
literally from honduras very difficult
to get through doggy
door especially you have a shih tzu not
a fan
um that was a pirate from captain
phillips captain now thank you i'm
jumping around a little bit
i'm american now kenosha i
belongs to me kenosha
wisconsin not your boy very big in
sheboygan this show so um but kenosha is
where this is
third day in a row speaking of cnn for
people who don't know this and we caught
this once live while we were doing a
stream when they had a tweet from a
white supremacist it was called like
aryan something and then
once we talked about it on air you were
here yeah
disappeared he doesn't even pay
attention to the show when he's on it
nope oh i at least do that yeah but it
was airy and
something and then they removed it well
this happened yesterday it's even better
with kenosha
while they're covering it watch what
changes here with the lower third let's
roll this clip and i'm going to talk
over it so i can video geographic very
hard
curfew ordered after violent protests
over police shooting of unarmed black
men in wisconsin that's what it's saying
underneath there with uh beans blitzer
there are a lot of investigations
and then look it goes away someone's
saying
being shot but what we do now it comes
back exact same thing
8 pm curfew ordered after protest they
just removed the word violence oh
in other words there was someone there
who wrote this up
and there was a jameson mind and she was
like oh what are you doing honest
journalism there that's not what we do
with this outfit here
and change it see exactly it's like
gross somebody
i want that because there's a high rod
on my desk by eight seconds from now
stilter won't have it it's just listen i
don't want to pay any more nuisance
money guys i love that they scrubbed it
it's just so fun my wife gets mad within
she gives me an allowance for my
nuisance money
they change it because they don't want
any violence against them like what
happened in atlanta
because they were like cnn at first like
oh my god they're trying to get a scene
and they're like oh
thank god they're just trying to burn
down the police precincts
um all right i've had to switch to pure
talk because of nuisance money
i can't afford the gold bond guys guys
stop no one uses money this is like two
days in a row that they actually did
journalism on accident with the fact
check first yesterday
removing violence i love it so kenosha
you were on a plane yesterday it was and
you watched the whole rnc and you were
like he walks in half fashion billy goes
did you see what happened in kenosha
yes i mean that's crazy it's just it's
incredible to me
about what the what's being allowed to
happen yeah but here's the thing that's
not
well you're getting a lot of people on
the ground like a lot of shafer who's
been on the show and right
um you know a friend of the show and
other folks who were on the ground i
almost killed him
hey elijah uh i'm sorry about that
[ __ ]
and then pretty close and yet what
you're not seeing
is anyone wanting to go talk to the
business owners and this is right
when you when you look at what happened
in minneapolis when you look at what's
happening in other cities
you don't you don't get a lot of
coverage and oh you barely get any
coverage in the mainstream media about
what's happening on the back end right
like what's happening you know this
morning
when i looked at cnn on cnn.com the only
thing i want to talk about is that uh
pro the protesters may have been shot
yeah when
they when you watch the video they were
attacking a guy right
yeah that's the problem right now is we
really if if people can assault you if
people can commit crime and burn down
cities and
commit what's likely over a billion
dollars in damage at this point last
time we tallied it was 700 million and
you know it's like detroit with murders
they're just trying to keep it so that
they're number one
and not so far ahead of a distant second
which by the way is also flint um gary
we know it's probably over a billion if
this damage is happening and your
businesses are being burned down your
black lives matter activists saying oh
you have insurance money
and you can't protect yourself or you
can't even protect your wife when being
accosted at a diner which we'll get to
in a second you don't live in a free
country
yeah you do not live in a free country
and republicans you need to step
up donald trump i get that you have your
rnc i'm not super impressed with
all of it okay some of it is good some
of it's a little bit hero worship
there are people out in the streets
being assaulted and their businesses are
being burned down
something more needs to be done at this
point this cannot continue
this is going to get a lot worse before
it gets better and the fact what makes
me i feel like i'm beating my head
against the wall when you look at the
jacob blake
trend it used to be with trayvon martin
there was a point where people would say
well you know he shouldn't have been
doing that and he was walking around you
know trayvon martin sure but you know
what
it doesn't mean that he should have lost
his life and and that can be true if he
didn't assault george zimmerman right or
even like with
with uh uh uh brown they would say well
you know he shouldn't do that but still
there should be de-escalation measures
at this point they've just not
acknowledged
any of it as it relates to blake none
they are so
transparent now where you have every
single major political leader from the
dnc when people say they exist on the
fringes
i guess the fringes have taken over
every major
office or appointment in the entire
democratic party they say this police
officer
needs to be charged for murder we have
more info here from a local news source
there's
i think there's the actual police call
um
jacob blake we obviously know that he
got into a tussle with the police
officers we showed you that where he was
wrestling with the cops beforehand
we told him that he had an active
warrant out for his arrest for sexual
assault
and domestic abuse uh but we also know
that he wasn't just breaking up a fight
he was trespassing he'd stolen a woman's
keys and cops were notified that he had
a warrant out for his arrest so that's
what they knew going in this is a guy
who has a history
of violence against police officers a
guy who has an active warrant
for his arrest because he committed
sexual assault and domestic abuse
and then he was resisting officers and
going into the car now maybe he didn't
have a gun maybe he was stealing
someone's car because he took the lady's
keys
why is there no correction and i'm going
to go out on a limb here and say
if the man is guilty of sexual assault
of rape yeah which is felony uh third
degree rape
if that's the case listen this isn't a
punishment through a justice system but
people always say you know what i think
these people should never be able to
rape again
there you go so if you don't want some
you know what not okay
there you go what happened to me too you
guys wanted the death penalty for people
in me too if it happened to be a
republican harvey weinstein
rug for a little bit because michelle
obama said he's a really good guy the
guy can't rape again or hit women unless
they get within striking distance of his
wheelchair
so let's just i'm just saying that
obviously we need to wait for all the
facts in the context to come
in but no one else is providing this
context
you would think it was a black man who
was walking away on a stroll
and the police walked up and shot him
yeah i don't know tell me what should
the police have done at this point
warrant out first that means that people
been trying to apprehend him for a while
yeah they tried to de-escalate it here
and you tossed the police off of him
and walked to the other side of the car
where he could have by the way had a
firearm which he
illegally was carrying before and
brandished in a bar
yeah but and the narrative that came out
i have no idea where people got this oh
he was just trying to make
break up a fight like they tried to put
him in this good samaritan role
and it's like well no that's actually
not what happened a woman called the
police on him because he wouldn't leave
and he'd stolen her car keys
and the police knew everything going on
by the way i agree i was i was trying to
break up a fight from the
she was trying to fight me no she's
trying to fight back fight but you know
yeah i had to fight off a [ __ ] she was
like give me my car keys i was like whoa
whoa whoa whoa you can't fight me
and i will say this i do believe in
de-escalation i believe that every one
of those perpetrators that had been shot
by the police
should have de-escalated they should
have complied with the officer's orders
and not walked to the car
with guns drawn and reached in okay i'm
sorry and if the taser doesn't work
just play parallel just just go with it
just do that just
give it to us you know what you know the
point you were making earlier about
you know with trayvon martin and then
kind of how these have gone you've said
oh
well people would kind of take a look at
the full picture but what's coming out
right now what's happened kind of in the
last 48 hours is
ignore every other fact all they want to
focus on
is a person's skin color and the fact
that he was shot
right like they don't want they don't
there's no consideration whatsoever
about the circumstances other than
cherry-picking the facts
that would make it look as as positive
as possible and it's not just in the
stories
it's in the headlines when you go
through the media and you're looking at
what are the headlines and the way that
they frame it
and i think i mean not even a stroll i
mean
they're almost trying to make it make it
like a brianna taylor type situation
like
a guy just out with his kids about to go
to a yoga appointment got right you know
cops dragged him out of the car and shot
him yeah and so now
everyone he was doing happy baby pose
and got lit up like the fourth of july
and and look i mean when you look at i
mean right we've seen the videos we've
seen what happened in that particular
situation
and what you're often hearing is i can't
believe that this happened it's a
tragedy every time someone gets shot
it's a tragedy
either for the person who felt they had
to use force or a person if they weren't
supposed to have force used against them
but no one is talking about anything
else it's just skin color yeah and by
the way it doesn't matter if you had a
gun on his car it couldn't be less
relevant than that yeah car is a deadly
weapon
exactly which likely wasn't his okay
officer hold on hold on a minute i'm
gonna commit grand theft
auto then you can arrest me then we'll
talk by the way that [ __ ] is crazy
she's asking for her keys and i don't
know
anything about that [ __ ] bye and as the
news is only focusing on the skin color
no wonder black people are scared yeah
right no no that's all they hear yeah
because they think that they're going to
get
down black people 80 something percent
we had this statistic not long ago
86 i believe still want the police at
least as much police presence or more
it's the black americans who have been
used as
pawns by the radical left which by the
way is largely spearheaded by white
people at this point
most black americans are disconnected
with this movement because their own
areas and businesses are being burned
down the people
who for some reason choose to be
represented by them are super wealthy
out of touch celebrities or athletes
who don't live in the kinds of
communities that black americans
have to exist in every single day and by
the way we're doing
record they were doing better than ever
on record because of donald trump's
problems
low unemployment right well and this is
this is why i get so pissed off at
leaders in the black community when they
come out like doc rivers was crying on
the news the other day
yesterday i think saying we're scared to
live in this country you know he
shouldn't have been shot and all that
stuff and lebron james is tweeting stuff
out and
every other person out there in the
black community is just saying this is
you can't do this you can't do this and
stirring people up
what do you think is gonna happen when
you do that when you when you one you're
lying
right you don't know the facts yet you
need to wait like everybody else and
figure it out
but two they're going to feel like they
have no other option than violence and
you're going to just be getting more
violence
that if that's your goal go for it
lebron james if it's not maybe wait a
second if you
can be objective if you believe that the
police officer who pulls you over
might as well be a violent mugger you're
going to treat them like a violent
exactly and that's what we're seeing
happening and statistically it's not
true it's based on a lie
speaking of black people kenosha that's
a surprise where the new riots are but
let's go to kenosha uh we just talked
about the chiron that was ring two
people were dead after a shooting in
kenosha
that's what you see in the news um i
want to clarify some rumors here some
people are saying that they're white
supremacists or the guy who shot them
was a white supremacist
um or that he was uh black he he could
have been
anti-black lives matter uh
not true i'm just trying to look here at
what the article says not true there's
no evidence that he was a white
supremacist can only be clear about that
as far as he was they were saying he was
a proud boy there's no evidence of that
maybe he was we don't know
he might he may have been a part of a
group that was actually there to protect
black lives matter
um along with you know properties from
looting and being burned down
or he could have been from this
libertarian group that was going on
uh there was a libertarian there was a
libertarian group that was there to
protect black lives matter
which doesn't make a whole lot anyway
yeah it does get confused it's like half
the people at reason magazine voting for
obama it's like oh yeah
all right that's one for you um or he
might have been
part of these organizations who were
there to protect businesses i don't
think the libertarian groups were
protecting businesses they were
protecting the black lives matter to
pave away for burning down
more car lots on their way to something
else um but here is a video clip
to show you why that may be the case the
longest you are not against each other
but they just want freedoms they just
want freedom liberty they want freedom
i'll burn down your cars
break to the head thank you that's so
sweet of you i believe it's somewhere in
the constitution i think it's somewhere
in the back let me find it oh
yeah these car lots burn them down yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think once i said that once
yeah well you know i think the fact that
they were you know they're following the
epa regulations with those mufflers
yeah and uh you know they got registered
by the state clearly the complicit
uh in slavery yeah well the key is also
masks
they were being safe oh we'll get to
that in a second because not all of them
work
but there's not a single comment about
that so let me be really clear
so far all of the evidence context can
change
uh some people are saying that now
there's more footage the initial clip
that was released was just this guy
shooting somebody
right then there was a more extended
clip which we're about to show you here
i warn you that it's graphic because
people do get shot
uh he was clearly defending himself when
people were pouncing on him
repeatedly couldn't be more clear-cut
self-defense now
people on the left are saying well
actually there's even more footage where
he was an active shooter before that
which
i don't really know that i believe
because like okay listen uh do you have
the footage of that
i can get it okay okay get it
then will you have the money all right
listen go get it if you have it you
should have it instantaneously
just take the edit bar and move it left
yeah just take on your iphone that
little thing extend clip to the left if
you have it so i don't believe it but
that in itself
is actually an acknowledgement that
context
changes the story everything we have
available to us
now at the time of this which is 10 40
a.m eastern on august 26th did i get
that right yes
yeah 26. jacob lake um tells us that
this man was acting in self-defense
here's the clip
you should have let the curb stomp
[Music]
happen
now he's getting away so once that fires
back at him
because it doesn't look like sounds like
it doesn't look like he's shooting him
yeah it looks like so someone could be
firing at him from afar he's like
walking
maybe he was shooting because there's
chaos going there but what is not in
doubt is that a man was trying to atomic
butt drop on him with his timberland he
shot him and i'm kind of impressed that
guy fired that rifle like a paintball
gun he just had it was
i don't feel bad the guy has the right
to defend himself if
that is out that's the context yeah if
he didn't walk up and go hey
and shoot somebody else before that
right in other words i don't care what
he said
i don't care if naughty words were
exchanged i don't even care
if he was a racist i'd prefer that he
would not be a racist i agree but it
doesn't give you the right to put
someone in a situation where they have
to defend life and limb
has it and unless you think this is
hyperbole uh has anyone ever been killed
by being stomped into the concrete
uh yeah yes a whole lot a whole lot of
people have but by the way the only way
that this changes is if he
was like you said an active shooter
every other scenario and if he was
i i searched high and low this morning
trying to find out if anybody could
confirm like i heard it i was like all
right can anybody confirm this i looked
everywhere that i could find
if it was out there somebody would be
black
one interesting thing is towards the end
of that clip the last person to get shot
right before he gets up
the guy is standing there moving towards
him he still doesn't shoot the guy the
guy gets three more steps closer and the
guy
i mean the way the fbi talks about it is
that if you're within seven yards like
almost all incidents are happening
within seven or eight yards
and that is the incident where like
someone can get to you before you can
draw or adequately
you know get right on them i mean from
that distance and they could still get
to you
and they could still get you and he
waits he still waits now
maybe he was trying to find the trigger
again or something like that but it
looks like he deliberately
maybe he didn't want to get fired and
end up on the nightly news because
they're going to vilify him no matter
what
it looks like he's hoping that guy's
going to just walk away because the
other guys got shot and instead that
that guy keeps coming at that point you
have to defend yourself we are long past
the point of nuisance money yeah it's
not gonna make him go away when he's
jumping on you with his boots
i tried it yeah that's hot but i did i
got my teeth fixed
so um this is actually a clip from him
again context
matters uh the shooter was filmed
earlier that night so kind of like
garrett foster and awesome everywhere
before and he was like
interviewing people or [ __ ] are not
going to do anything i'm bringing my gun
down you're like oh that guy seems like
he might be an agitator
in this case we have footage of this man
before the shooting earlier in the night
where he was helping
injured protesters and i don't know if
this is true or not he claims to be an
emt but
the fact remains as you watch this he
clearly is out there to help some
protesters
now if i can ask can you guys step back
medical ems right here
that's a far cry from curb stomping a
man yeah it seems like even if he's
there
delicious to me even if he's there as a
militiaman let's say let's say he's a
proud boy
slash minuteman who just came from the
bundy ranch
he still is there trying to help someone
who might be an ideological adversary
not stomp them into the dirt yeah
exactly which tends to make me think he
wasn't an active shooter
also because there's no evidence of that
and uh black lives matter and antifa
are filthy pricks who lie about
everything yeah well and you know if you
want to see more stuff
exactly you've done well you've done
well there's my evidence gavel drop yeah
exactly but i mean if you want to see if
you want to see more stuff like this
just keep pulling police out of areas
just keep
making citizens put into a position
where they have to defend themselves not
not where they want to go out there and
do that i don't think any of these guys
want to be out there doing this but when
nobody else is protecting your
businesses or life and limb
out in these communities what are you
supposed to do yeah it needs to stop
working
to quote the uh the clown face killer
from yesterday uh who said you know it
wasn't a problem until it was a problem
okay oh okay uh
right now where they're intimidating and
assaulting people in the streets
it's been working for them yeah and it
needs to stop working for them yeah
that's what needs to happen yeah people
do need to stand up for themselves i'm
not saying go out looking for it i'm not
saying that you commit assaults
these people and these people i mean
black white red yellow and antiphon
black lives matter right it's not a
monolith
it's it's a multicolored rainbow of
[ __ ]
what's at the end of the rainbow oh a
part of another [ __ ]
[Applause]
so don't say they what do you mean you
people the organization the people who
are involved the people who try and
curb stomp folks and some people are
going to try and factor me it wasn't a
curb he was in the middle okay
median stomp folks they need to
uh it needs to stop working for them
yeah don't go out and act like them but
you need to protect yourself and there
are steps that you can take to do so so
that legally hopefully you're protected
as much as possible
um but we are at the point now where too
many people have been brutally beaten
and there is no help coming from their
uh local representatives
certainly not from national
representatives in the dnc and we have
not seen enough from president donald
trump or republicans
this is at the point it's a boiling
point where we need to see more done
people need to feel that they can go to
their place of work
or their apartment in the city and not
fear for their life
just because of the color of their skin
or god forbid
they're a black person who think for
themselves 30 something percent now who
support donald trump and they're called
an uncle tom and they get their ass
kicked too
well you know a lot of this isn't even
about that right a lot of the businesses
being destroyed are minority owned by
now yeah
yeah i mean they're out there saying
they're part of this are you doing bill
bill they
no but think about think about the riots
every single time
the riots the burning of buildings the
looting takes place
in minority-owned communities
predominantly it does go other places
but it's like
you burn down your own neighborhood what
the hell's the matter with you remember
goodyear tires banned their employees
from having modern hats or promoting any
conservative causes but they said that
black lives matter is okay
they supply free tires for all the used
car lots in kenosha don't you put your
your rubber where your mouth is and step
up screw good what do you have to lose
your stock price has been taking a dip
no one likes you
at least in the blimp yeah well yeah
well here you know we we've gotta be
there
this is an entire generation of people
that grew up in school that had no
limits right when we grew up if we
mouthed off to the wrong guy too much we
got popped in the face eventually we we
learned where the line was and we let it
float
yeah pop to the face with a fist right
we learned there's a line there are
consequences
you've got an entire generation out
there protesting this that have no idea
that there are consequences for their
actions yeah you cannot attack somebody
and expect to walk away alive
if you threaten that person's life you
just can't well they can now because
they have been
no that's what i'm saying you're right
i'm just kind of reiterating that point
but it's like this entire generation has
no clue how this works it needs to well
unfortunately i think that you you i
think you're gerald
you're glad your clip you don't even
know what how this works is
no seriously this is how this works
right now no i know until something is
done it's never worked this way before
no and there's a reason why yeah it's
not meant to work this way by the way
hit the notification bell because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot
uh on the on the youtubes every morning
at 10 a.m eastern tune in monday through
thursday tomorrow night of course we
have the uh
the live stream going on uh follow us on
social media so you know all the details
patriotic costume contest drinking game
and uh we really do appreciate
notifications to let you know when we
have other videos that go up
uh we also have a sponsor to uh well
obviously a wonderful sponsor the show
black rifle coffee
and uh one of our interns even brendan
is here to showcase
mr even brendan tell us about our
sponsor for today
for coffee okay well yeah we figured
that
no so beyond black sorry i didn't like
him and we didn't michael
oh no you gotta lean in yeah it's the
beyond
black black rifle did you just look at
it for the first time
[Applause]
there you go get in there he's reading
all right get a little bit of that which
do you prefer there brendan which blend
is your favorite
i do not drink coffee but if not
probably go with the vintage or this
okay good well the vintage is sold out
so that helps there you go listeners
and where can people go to get their
promo code uh
black rifle. coffee.
blackriflecoffee.com slash crowder
entering promo code crowder 20
off for black riffle coffee thank you
the sponsors thank you brendan we
appreciate you modeling it for us yeah
oh my gosh that's brendan
twenty percent off your first order
twenty percent off your first door
that's pretty good i mean
yeah he handled that i like this
silencer smooth mine doesn't work mine's
broken yours is broken we broke it on
purpose gerald
that's because you're non-controlled my
first gang banging all right
we have something else by the way the
george floyd autopsy that was a drive-by
uh
not so much it was just really uh an
unfair fight
[Laughter]
love you brendan just because there's
wheels on your chair doesn't make it a
drive-by
what i love is that he didn't seem
surprised he didn't seem to yeah i think
he saw it coming yeah whatever
he took it like another place of work
okay
what happens when you don't use the
product you can't drink pepsi when you
work for coke
um george floyd autopsy just for people
who don't know uh dr andrew baker he's a
chief
medical uh uh examiner uh they concluded
now they did do an autopsy on george
floyd
and just because facts should matter uh
overdose
the cause of death uh the document says
that the level of fentanyl
in floyd's blood was quote fatal under
normal circumstances and they said that
if floyd
had been found dead in his home or
anywhere else and there was no other
contributing factors
he would conclude that it was in
overdose death
and i know that people overdose on me
yeah overdose on me but i know they're
going to say well
the family who hired their own objective
medical examiner said
that it didn't help that uh uh derek
chavez
was on his neck and no one's arguing
that but this was a guy who died from an
overdose and a heart condition
yeah it shouldn't matter and again
unfortunately that in tandem
with the full tape which we showed from
from pillar to post the entire tape on
here
there is no evidence whatsoever of
malicious intent
no evidence of racism no evidence of
intent to murder
and we do have evidence that this is how
the police officers were trained in that
department right this guy's only sin was
following bad training my position has
changed
zero unfortunately the medical examiner
said but uh we're still gonna uh
consider it homicide because uh you know
because we don't wanna lose our justice
well i think i made the point yesterday
to you about this and you said look
that's how he was training us saying the
only thing he did wrong was not turning
the guy on his side i think that's
at that point we can say okay they've
done everything they can before this
george floyd obviously had way too much
trains to live very long anyway yeah
that was the thing and you're like no
that's exactly what they were trained
today you were trained i didn't know
that
i'd rather be on my stomach because if
you turn me on my left side i have to
pee
just on your left side that's kind of
weird no it's talking about some kind of
a nerve does someone out there know that
a doctor told me don't sleep on your
left side because that makes you have to
urinate
that's not true my prostate is the size
of a grapefruit
maybe that i need some of that saw
palmetto what some of that new genix
that that black guy keeps talking about
frank thomas a white sock frank thomas
you're looking forward
to this white side players so now you're
trying to pull a gotcha
i'm talking about his socks nobody
watches people
i'm curious what everyone thinks is
going to happen when they charge the
trial come or the charges are dropped
they're not going to be dropped
or they're not yeah i actually don't
think they're going to get dropped
but you don't i don't think they're
going to get dropped no they think
they'll be lower
for political reasons they're going to
keep pushing them forward and they're
going to get to a trial and it ain't
going to go the way do you think he's
going to get second degree still
yes i don't think it's the right call
but but you think that'll happen
i think they're they seem so committed
to they want to hunt themselves into a
corner
before they had any evidence they were
like we're definitely definitely
definitely gonna definitely do this guys
i don't think you should you should wait
you should maybe think about it yeah
nope definitely we're
we're all in like elizabeth warren and
bernie sanders and jacob
uh blake they're like oh this man needs
to be prosecuted in charge they don't
care about the information that comes
out no
right then it's just silence it's kind
of like sanchez if you follow anyone
think of it this way if you follow every
single
presidential candidate from the dnc from
the primaries every single one
and if you watch every single major
network abc nbc cbs cnn msnbc not named
fox news
you not you would know nothing about the
jacob lake case
and you would have never heard the
follow-up of nick sandman those people
if you watched all those come on the
entire dnc abc nbc cbs cnn
msnbc cnbc all of them you would still
think nick sandman went out and
assaulted
an old native american man in leviticus
that's why he was missing
to this day because they never they
never covered the follow-up
yeah and we wonder why there's a chasm
oh i want to be a centrist you're just
going to be standing in the middle with
no one
yeah we'll be ready for this by the way
if you think the aftermath of the rodney
king verdict was bad
in this country be ready because you're
right bill i i am
100 convinced there is no way they're
going to change the charges because do
you imagine how
much crap the person that did that would
get they would be run out of political
office
death threats people would be marching
on his house no matter if it was the
right call or not
and when it comes back that they're not
guilty from this it will explode things
there's still people who say who think
that hands up don't shoot was a thing
it's not no except trying to make it a
thing
not a thing ever so on top of that if
they the further they reduce the charges
the more likely it is
that uh qualified immunity will apply
because the further you get down that
scale of
you know intentional crime or you know
doing something recklessly or whatnot
that applies even more because of of the
way that uh the structure is built and
and i really do think that they've boxed
themselves into a corner
and then when it comes out it will be
very it will be very bad i mean and
really the
this is why not sitting down and saying
that we have to draw a line with the
protests and the violence
and all of that is a problem because it
just means when there
is other things that people think that
they should protest about
yeah if you really want to make a
statement well now you set the bar
you know lower or higher depending
higher flames lower you know dignity
for america you know respect for
property and people um and so that's
if you don't if we don't cap it details
no problem but none of these guys will
be in office anymore so it won't matter
i love the fire babe yeah it's uh i
don't know why i'm saying we didn't
like that character i just feel like i
need to do a different black voice every
now and then oh
that's good it's a guy it's the black
guy with yarmulke
fire flame ground whopper um sounds
almost like bill cosby i have no idea
what he's doing
not the rape though i don't want to sell
him not that he's not kind of a jewish
black guy no no no
sammy davis jr he's america's dad no i
think here's what i want in the light of
this new evidence that there's an
overdose right that this guy
obviously was high out of his mind and
he was asked about that from the police
officers
talking about intent and second degree
okay i want you to think of any lynching
historically that's ever happened
all right any lynching you know what
let's scale that back think of any
incident where there is police brutality
with intent not only to kill intent to
harm yeah
let's even scale it back any time that a
a racist
officer abused his authority and was
looking to stick it to a black and not
even killed them
did any of those ever include an over
10 minute interaction with a non-violent
arrest
and an officer offering to put him in
the back of an
air-conditioned car with the window down
and he would stay with him to make sure
he was comfortable
has that ever happened in the history of
[ __ ] mankind
no no i don't think so take a stab at it
i'd like to see the receipts and i hope
this officer i hope if this officer does
get get off which i know you probably
think is unlikely i i sure hope he gets
a whole lot of nuisance
money it's just you sing nuisance money
grows on trees
you know what's terrible about it is if
he does beat the charges he won't get
anything
no he won't
but the part about it you know the whole
like not guilty part
again if that happens won't be the
covered part as opposed to
jacob blake who uh who is charged with
sexual
with rape in the third degree serial
domestic abuse
injures officers and is now a
millionaire yeah
exactly the go fund me oh gosh well look
and this is one of the reasons
this is one of the reasons that i get
pissed off at the media for not
reporting
accurate information because it leads to
we're in a no-win situation
right if he gets off that's justice i
mean it based on what we know that seems
like justice that he's not guilty of the
charges that will likely be brought
against him
if he's found not guilty that's justice
but will burn right the whole place is
going to burn down because people are
going to riot
if he goes to jail that's not justice
right and so an innocent man
is going to jail if he's innocent that's
not justice well you
but is it the decision is it the
decision what we're waiting for
we it is justice if he is convicted no
not every time a jury comes back with a
verdict they're right right oh you're
saying if they come with the wrong one
i'm saying yeah they're saying if they
come back with the wrong one and say
this guy is guilty of murder
guilty of murder which is not true but
but are we deciding now that it's
like we are already deciding that if
he's found guilty he's well
unfortunately the jury pool has been
tainted at this point as the issue i'm
very
different i'm willing to believe both
ways so
what you're saying then is there's no
you just told us the system was corrupt
you just said they box themselves in
that there's no way they could give an
accurate verdict at this point that it
wouldn't be allowable not what i said
what i said was that they are going to
charge him with a crime
right that they cannot win on and then
ultimately they're going to have a
problem at the end because they're going
to lose so
most likely based on the evidence we see
oh you think they will if it's if they
say
they will likely agree it's not going to
change if it is a
if it is a judge trial and a bench trial
right is that what you call it if it's a
bench trial i fully understand what
you're saying and i agree with you if it
is a jury
people are basing all of their yeah but
you think the new genetics guy wears
white socks uh let's move on to people
being ass because then we do have to go
to mug club soon after this
according to manny let's go to people
being assaulted in diners because a lot
of
listen you could argue that as police as
it relates to police officers right in
in convicted felons or as it relates to
people protecting their businesses and
convicted felons that all those people
sort of picked aside and they were
involved either in riots or protecting
or protecting citizenry so they're all
at fault right
it's one of those zero tolerance
policies like in high school you can
have your face being beaten in
and you shove the guy off and you both
get suspended
bust up man let's go now to people who
had nothing to do with these protests at
all
this is happening uh more and more now
in cities across the united states
where they are then accosted and
assaulted while just trying to enjoy
their meal this could be you next
according to black lives matter
[Applause]
wow
put your fists up that's what they're
saying put your fist up
put your mask on now huh
yelling at him to put his fist up and
that guy look at that guy next to her
look at that guy man that guy next with
his fist up like please
devour me last please
just give me an extra few minutes so i
can say my goodbyes
what are you guys what an ass right guys
like you're not stopping an assault and
let's be clear assault is not battery
getting in someone's
racing demanded to put their fists up
now this is something i want what
my question today this is important
because you see a lot of internet tough
guys responding and a lot of internet
not so tough guys responding i think
both are wrong
people saying well you should sit there
and take it i don't agree people saying
you should run away
having experienced this ourselves they
follow you you turn your back they're
like the little ghost from super mario
world they follow you wherever you go
it's not something that's it's not an
option that's available to you and then
some people saying
well you know what i would just go after
them that's also incorrect so this is my
advice to you um and we've we've learned
about these uh kind of some of these
techniques i guess when you do a
concealed carry class massage has been
on the show
one thing that you need to know is if
you listen to police officers when
they're saying
drop the gun drop the gun hey everyone
there's an active shooter please
find cover what they're doing is
creating witnesses because in the chaos
of violence people tend to forget
and then afterwards they'll sort of
patch it together and it may not be
accurate so what you need to do when
this is happening and someone's getting
in your face and someone is assaulting
you
let me go through the steps de-escalate
as best you can while simultaneously
creating witnesses
hey listen i don't know you you're a
stranger i'm uncomfortable please get
out of my space
protect the most vul as you do that
simultaneously make sure someone's
filming
you don't want them to take one clip out
of context you film all of it
then also protect the most vulnerable
among you the way that guy stood up was
his wife
her back was facing the mob and i have a
wife right now who's compromised with
gbs i would say sweetheart
get inside call the police officers
start filming okay
listen just please leave me alone i want
to eat my meal and then if they get
within physical distance of you where
you are threatened
take care of business and i want to be
clear here you should never hit a woman
but that's not about a woman versus a
man that's a woman with
20 people who are yelling at this man
and threatening him
it could not be less relevant if your
wife or family
are in endangered do not come out
swinging but don't sit there and take it
do not kneel do not put up your fist it
doesn't matter because they probably
move on to that guy next and then didn't
save the clip
and uh do not uh run it's not an option
that's available to you it doesn't
matter
create witnesses de-escalate film
protect the most vulnerable among you
and then have your line already drawn in
your mind beforehand
where you know if some people that's
don't get i've often said this when
we've had hospitals i say hey listen
don't get i can't let you get in within
arm's length of me yeah right
stay over if you stay there you're fine
i've made it very clear and that's been
on camera
maybe yours is someone pushes you
legally that line uh half vision bill
can tell us a little bit more clearly
what it is
but it depends on the state and also
notice that these attacks these assaults
are happening in states where you can't
carry or defend yourself exactly
nice and i this this really hit me hard
because when i saw this i started
thinking through like literally i
started putting myself in a position
where i'm with my family and for me
that's my wife and
a newborn if i'm you know a couple
months from now when his immune system's
up i'm out at a restaurant
i'm in a very dangerous situation where
i the best case scenario if things go
south is that i get my butt kicked in
front of my wife and she can't do
anything about it and she's crying and
it's something that will stay with us
for the rest of our lives
worst case scenario my wife and my child
potentially because mobs don't exactly
act rationally it happens all the time
women get hurt yeah kids and the only
reason that this would happen is because
a group of people walked by and said
because i didn't put my fist in the air
i'm a racist
right that's what they said that needs
to stop working that's fashion
people and this is why i say this don't
sit there take it do not put up your
fist
if you're too afraid to try and
de-escalate and film and protect those
among you are the most vulnerable among
you then at the very least
don't raise a fist and i would also
recommend asking for a steak knife for
your soup
i think the advice is spot on because
only through
engaging those different techniques can
you maintain your safety in the variety
of ways that are necessary right if you
can try and move away if you can't
you've got it on film
you're trying to correct the record or
make sure that it's safe and
understanding you get other people
involved right you never know who's
nearby but
those people can't be advantageous to
you if you're not vocalizing
right you know i need you to stay away i
don't know you i'm uncomfortable i'm
feeling threatened etc etc
um you know one of the the hard things
that i when looking in those various
clips
is business owners right yeah and
they're letting it like they're standing
in there and think about it
you got a person who maybe it's a
restaurant they're just now finally
getting some business
and they're in their mind going wait a
minute if i walk outside okay my
restaurant's getting burned down tonight
all my workers are going home i can't
feed my community uh
what what am i doing and i don't know
what the good answer is and the reason
is
because the minus owner shouldn't have
to answer no but there's no excuse at
this point because when you have people
who say
you're with us or you're a race they're
not even saying you're with us or
against us they're saying you're with us
raise your fist which by the way has all
kinds of historical connotations
communism
you silly [ __ ] put up your fish you're
either with us
or you're a racist so i now say to
business owners
hey i don't think you're i don't care if
you're a democrat or republican but if
i'm eating your establishment
it's your job to make sure that it's a
safe eating experience and don't come
complaining to me when i stiff you on
the bill i would leave if the kitchen
were on fire
i'm certainly going to leave when people
are physically accosting me and you're
not doing anything
there is no option at this point to
remain neutral here's the beauty right
everyone who's not a radical democrat
meaning the entire dnc in media
establishment
you all we expect of you is just to not
let people around you be hurt
yeah that's it exactly you're a business
owner don't let people your business be
hurt
you're a man and there are people around
you who are women and maybe vulnerable
older people
don't let them be hurt you're out in a
parking lot that they're trying to set a
blaze
don't let them be heard i don't care if
you're a democrat i don't care if you're
john kasich's third and nephew
before fourth time removed i don't even
know what that means
i don't care if you're the most
insufferable jackass on the planet
i am not saying you're with us or you're
racist i'm not saying you're with us or
you're with black lives matter that's
what they're saying you put your fist up
or you're a racist which by the way
justifies protesting looting and assault
we hear that from the black holes matter
organization i'm just saying
you either prevent people from being
hurt in civil society
or you are an enemy and i think that's a
pretty wide berth that we're giving you
if you can't find some way to parallel
park in there
well then guess what i'm not going to
complain when they devour you last we
actually need to tell youtube we're
going to go to web extended for mug club
members a lot of credit.com club uh also
because uh
i from what i understand smooth manny
may say some things that might not over
so well
it's behind the paywall the truth
according to smooth manny will be coming
up it is saturn's cubes
youtube saturn i don't like it and
neither does half asian bill but right
now
youtube it's time for youtube piss off